If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God,
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears, then you will also appear with him. And,
Well, happy Sunday Church. Uh, what a blessing it is to get to gather like this.
What a privilege.
Really it is that God has invited us into his presence and we get to do this
every Sunday. Uh, we shouldn't take it for granted for sure. Uh,
today we're continuing through our journey in the New Testament book of
Colossians.
And so you can go ahead and take your copy of God's Word and turn with me to
Colossians chapter three, verse 12, Colossians three,
starting in verse 12. Today as we get into this,
many of you know this about me already, but I don't like coffee.
And so before you start throwing stones at me for that or judging me too
harshly, I, I think I have an excuse. See, a couple years ago, my family,
we had genetic testing done for various reasons. And, and one of the,
the markers that showed up on the genetic testing was related to that.
Actually, I might be wondering how well the nutritionist,
as we sat down with her,
she said that this one specific line of code makes bitter things taste
more bitter. So she could have been completely pulling my chain.
I don't know how, if that's true or not, but I'm gonna hold onto that one. Okay?
Like it's in my DNA that I feel like that, um, no, but think about it.
If we could somehow go in and,
and we could change that specific line of code, then,
then I would flip the switch and I would be all in on pumpkin spice
lattes, fra double shots, white espresso, whatever.
I don't even know how to order that. Okay? But, but that's how it works.
Somehow I would be excited and it would taste good to me at that point.
Listen, that's similar to how the old self
versus new self works in our lives.
See, in our old flesh driven sinful self that we are born into,
that we live in, in light of our sin nature in that state,
we don't enjoy things like patience and
kindness and forgiveness.
But when God makes us a new creation,
he rewires and empowers our hearts to pursue those
things. Now those things actually fit us. We, we,
we taste those well now they taste good to us.
That's what we're gonna see today. If it, if we saw last week, this old self,
today we're gonna see the stark contrast to what we see in
God's work in us. That, that the old self was dominated by sin.
It was directed by the ways of the world.
It was standing against God in so many ways. The new self is totally different.
Look now at Colossians three, verses 12 through 17,
this new self he describes
put on then as God's chosen ones, holy and beloved,
compassionate hearts, kindness, humility,
meekness and patience bearing with one another.
And if one has a complaint against another,
forgiving each other as the Lord has forgiven you.
So you also must forgive. And above all of these,
put on love which binds everything together in perfect harmony.
And let the peace of Christ rule in your hearts to which
indeed you were called in one body. And be thankful.
Let the word of Christ dwell in you richly teaching and admonishing one another
in all wisdom.
Singing Psalms and hymns and spiritual songs with thankfulness in your
hearts to God. And whatever you do in word or deed,
do everything in the name of the Lord Jesus,
giving thanks to God the Father through him. Lord,
we need you to show us from your word what you
want us to be like.
I pray you'd remove any barriers in our arts and our minds clarify,
awaken us if we need it today,
that we would see clearly the difference between the old and
the new that you have done in us. Help us God.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So you remember that this passage does not happen in isolation.
Like we're not just pulling this out of nowhere.
This must be taken in context that these believers in Colossae were in the midst
of a depraved, pluralistic culture.
A lot of different things they were hearing and saying.
And as Paul reminded the church of the Gospel and of the fact that Christ is
above all competitors, what he was saying here,
he's saying what that does is it changes you.
It actually creates a new life in you.
It changes you to reflect Christ's power.
But that was hard.
To live that out in that situation was hard. It's still hard.
And so that's why he needed to start with the reasons they can put on the new
self. So we started with with why they are able.
What is the reason you can,
how is it possible that you can put on this new self, live a new life,
put on the new robe of christlikeness? How can you,
well, we looked at this last week in verse 10 above.
Go back up there just a couple verses ahead of where we are today.
Not only have you put off the old self, that was verse nine,
but verse 10 and have put on the new self,
which is being renewed in knowledge after the image of its creator.
And so this has already happened. It says,
so not only have you put off the old self that if you are a new creation by
faith in Jesus' life, death and resurrection, then what you see here,
he's now reforming you for him, right?
We saw that he's reformed.
You are reformed in the new creation for him. Now
he's making you into the image in which you were originally intended to live,
which is his image, that image that perfectly displayed in Jesus.
Colossians one 15. He's saying, this is what you should be like now
increasingly over your life. And so what the saying by this, again,
the reason you can put on the new self is because you are new already.
That means you can put on the new self live like that because you already are.
Just live it out now.
Just kind of take what you already are and live it out daily.
But then you look again at verse 12, the first few words it says put on.
Then that then is tracking us back to verse 10.
Put on then as God's chosen ones, holy and beloved
as meaning. You already are these things. So just live it out.
You can put on the new self. What kind of things? Well, first he says,
you are God's chosen ones.
God's chosen ones.
I want you to hear the way he says it in the parallel book to this,
which is Ephesians. This is Ephesians one, verses three through six.
Blessed be the God and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ,
who has blessed us in Christ with every spiritual blessing in the heavenly
places,
even as he chose us in him before the foundation of the world,
that we should be holy and blameless before him. Sounds familiar,
right in love.
He predestined us for adoption to himself as sons
through Jesus Christ according to the purpose of his will,
to the praise of his glorious grace with which he's blessed us in the beloved.
So I want you just to stop and think for a second how stunning that reality is
that a holy God would choose to make sinful
humans a part of his family,
just stop and think holy other pure.
And he says, no, I'm gonna take sinful humans and make them a part of my family.
Plus he would pay the cost for that to happen with his very son's life.
And he didn't have to do it like we're not good enough that he had to.
He could have, he had the right to save nobody. He's holy.
We're not. He could have just said no to everything, but because he loves
'cause of his grace, he does save,
but he doesn't just choose and then leave you hanging right here.
You're a part of my family now. And then you figure it out yourself. No,
what does it say? He also makes you. Verse 12 says, holy and beloved.
So God's chosen once, holy and beloved.
Now, that word beloved, we don't use very often,
but that word in the original language means cherished,
treasured
that you hold something in high esteem.
And so I don't know what you walked in here with today,
what your past has told you. You are the enemy tells you, you are
that Christian.
That is how your heavenly Father views you.
Beloved cherished, treasured.
That's how he views you as you're, he's making you a new creation.
You've believed he's made you right before him.
He's made you holy before him and he's made you his treasured child.
Does that not stir your affection for him then
that he had every right to kick you out and keep you out? And he said, no,
you're gonna be my child. I choose you. I'm adopting you. I'm making you holy.
I'm making you blameless. I'm making you mine. He says,
so when you think about it, you are new,
you're chosen by God, you're holy and beloved by God.
That means you can put on the new self.
He's given you the ability to do that. But it's also reality that you should
like not only can you, you should put on the new self.
Why? Why should you put on the new self? Well, back to verse 11.
I mentioned this briefly last week. Colossians three 11.
Listen to what it says here.
There is not Greek and Jews, circumcised, uncircumcised, barbarians,
gith and slave free. But Christ is all and in all.
Now we're gonna talk a lot about that verse next week when we get to
relationships. But, but look at the little word that starts verse 11.
It says here,
that's an adverb of location which refers here to the
sphere of the new self. Like he's made you new,
you are new. So here in this arena, in this state,
here's where it plays out.
So this is what I referred to last week as I called the new creation kingdom.
So why should you put on the new self?
Because you are in this new creation kingdom now.
Now what's that? That's his rule and reign in his people.
That's God's oversight and control and, and direction.
Both individually in our lives we're members of his kingdom,
but also collectively we are his kingdom.
A new creation group of people together.
So why should you?
Because he has made you new and in this kingdom,
this is how you do it.
That means the rest of this that we'll see today and all the way through the
next few chapters is showing us what this new creation kingdom
looks like.
That this is the arena in which you are to live out the new kingdom's values.
It's not the kingdom of this here that we should live for.
His kingdom is what we now live for. Okay?
So then the question is, what does it look like to put on the new self?
We know we can. We know we should. Okay, what does that look like?
How do we do this? What?
What does it look like for us to live out these values?
Well, when you look back to Colossians three, 12 through 17, what I read before,
you see the word heart show up twice. So the first
arena this plays out is in our hearts.
And really you could make the argument that all of it stems from the attitude of
your heart, right? That this, this plays out. So how do we put on the new self?
What does it look like? Well, first it happens in our hearts.
'cause remember what Jesus said back in Luke 6 45. I know you have all that.
All of you have that memorized, but lemme just remind you of that.
Luke 6 45 says,
the good person outta the good treasure of his heart produces good.
And the evil person outta the evil treasure produces evil
For out of the abundance of the heart, his his mouth speaks.
What's Jesus teaching?
He's teaching that what's in there is eventually gonna come out.
This controls, this drives from here is what happens out there,
whether that's good or bad, whether that's new self or old self,
what's in there is going to show up.
And so what we see in Colossians three last week, five through 11,
was when the old self, the old heart is in there. That's what you get.
Now this is, this is the new heart. This is what the new self looks like.
So verse 12, you see compassionate hearts,
there's a compassionate heart, meaning when someone else hurts, you hurt.
That's what compassion is In the old self,
we were pleased when someone else hurt, right?
Felt good when we made someone else painful or when they were walking through
life and they, they missed the the field goal, right? Like that's it feels,
it feels good when they suffer.
Now the new self is what Jesus did when he saw the lost helpless crowd around.
What did he do? He had compassion on them. He hurt for them.
That's new self stuff.
He also says kindness here.
Part of the heart change that Galatians five says is a fruit of God's spirit
working in you. What is kindness?
Kindness is rather than being selfish and wanting people to serve you,
you're warm and you're sweet as you serve other people,
you don't have an edge to you. If you know what I mean by that.
You're kind people love to be around you.
Verse 12 also says, humility. This is part of the new heart,
is what Philippians two, three says.
Counting others more significant than yourselves.
That's new heart stuff that you're humble,
where you're putting a priority on others more than yourself.
He also says, another aspect of this heart change is meekness. Again,
we don't use that ver word very much, but verse 12 says, meekness,
which is not what we might tend to think of. Passivity,
meek kind of just weak. No meekness is strength under control.
It's the same word that Jesus uses in Matthew 11 when he says he is gentle.
Meekness is the same word there. And so when you think about Jesus, remember he,
he flipped tables. He called out hypocrisy.
But meekness means he knew when to deploy his strength.
And he was talking about it in a way that he knew how he knew.
He knew how to deploy his strength to protect, to care for the hurting.
That's when he used his strength. But other than that, he was under control.
He was meek. That's new heart stuff in us.
And then he says Patience. That last word in verse 12, patience.
That's one aspect of the hig piff unity that we must maintain in the church,
right? Humility, generalist, patience, forbearance. That's Ephesians four.
To maintain unity,
we must have patience with one another because we are all still in
the renewal process of the new self.
We're not finished yet. That's Philippians one,
six that's coming someday when Jesus returns will be finished until that time
comes. Two Corinthians three 18 says,
it's God's spirit who works in us to conform us to the image of Christ.
And that's a lifelong process. We're not conformed fully yet.
So I can't expect you to be something you're not yet
that, that you'll be five years from now. But you're not able to be that yet.
God is still working on you to make you what you ought to be. Right?
That's his process of sanctification. That means I must be patient
parenting, right? Be patient with our kids as they grow,
that they can be expected to do more and more as you grow.
But it's not for a five year old to be expected to do what an 18 year old can
allow God to work in us to grow.
He says in verse 15,
and part of this heart change in the new self is that we are to let the peace of
Christ, the peace coming from Christ rule in our hearts.
That means it has control our, here's what that means.
Our default,
when we experience differences between brothers and sisters,
our default should be to let the peace of Christ rule it has
control. It says how it goes, right? That should be first.
That's the new heart. New self is peace.
Even the word of Christ. Verse 16 is to dwell in you richly.
That's in your hearts, right? We're talking,
this is the first sphere that the new self works is in your heart.
The word of Christ dwells.
It's given room in the deepest part of who you are.
It directs, it instructs. It says, this is how you do this.
This is how you don't do this. It guides our decisions.
It instructs us how to respond to each other.
The word of Christ has to dwell deep within us,
which leads to a heart of thanksgiving three times in the last three verses I
read, Thanksgiving shows up, which in dark circumstances is hard.
But that means your heart has to be different.
When you face hard times that you can still see God's goodness in it.
That's the heart of thanksgiving. The new heart.
That's what the new new self looks like internally, that the heart's different.
What comes out of you is different then, right? It's got a new core,
it has new tastes, right?
The DNA structure has changed to taste these things as good as before it
wasn't. And when you think about all of that,
about the heart,
think about then how different our relationships would be as a result of that,
right? If that's a new heart,
if that's the new self within us, dominated controlling us,
think how different our relationships would then be.
If you read carefully as I was looking through this,
you notice this entire passage is plural,
which means that it's about the life of the church.
It's about the life of believers living together, the new covenant,
kingdom citizens that we are. We're living it out together,
not just you on your own. This is us.
And this is so critical because of what Jesus said in John 13,
that a new commandment I give to you that you love one another just as I have
loved you. You also are to one another.
And by this,
all people will know that you are my disciples if you have love for one another.
In other words, the way we interact proves our faith to the world.
We're not. That's what Jesus said.
That's why Paul in Colossians three is so firm
about the way our relationships are to be so different than the ways of the
world.
Look at this. Verse 13. He says,
we are to bear with one another.
And if one has a complaint against another for forgive each other,
here's our natural tendency. When we have a complaint against someone,
we go talk to a bunch of other people and we rally the troops and get 'em on our
side,
and we start to create camps and start to create factions and say,
we're all against them. Listen, that is the wrong way to do it.
Our first instinct should be one of forgiveness.
Our first instinct should be one to let go of the complaint.
That's what it says now. Now,
will you still feel the sting of someone hurting you or wronging you?
Yes.
But what this means is that you forfeit your right to express
your anger, to parade your hurt,
to demand reparation now.
Now this doesn't say you can't lovingly confront that person over the wrong,
they've committed against you. That's Matthew 18.
It just means you go about it with kindness and patience.
You remove the log in your eye as you go to them for their speck in theirs.
Plus,
I'm not saying that you have to trust them immediately.
'cause trust is earned over time. Forgiveness happens. Trust is built.
But listen, when you are hurt and you initiate forgiveness,
that reflects God's character and it reflects this
distinctive trait of the new covenant kingdom
of how we interact, of how we are to be with one another.
Everybody else out there, the way of the world is resentment.
A cycle of revenge.
What if we were different here?
What if this became our mantra that as the Lord has forgiven me,
so I'm going to forgive you?
What if that became what we lived out the gospel truth of that,
what if that became the dominant way of speaking and living?
Here's what I know would happen. There'd be less gossip,
there'd be fewer side eye glances on Sundays when you're here in the same
building together. There'd be fewer broken relationships.
There'd be fewer church splits.
If this became our driving force, we must be better at this church.
'cause listen, if we can't figure this out, who else can?
If we have been forgiven by a holy God, if we can't figure this out,
who else can? And if we don't, the world does not see Christ's love.
And listen, don't think I'm up here. Self righteously,
just condemning everybody else.
This has been a problem in my extended family.
This has been a problem on every single church staff I've ever served on in my
whole life.
We have to be better and listen,
the only way we can get there is not, we can't just like choose. Yeah,
I'm gonna do that now. No, the only way we get to that kind of culture,
the only way we could ever walk in unity and perfect harmony as it says,
verse 14 is if we put on love,
one Corinthians 13, 13 says, love is the greatest of all.
It's what he says here. It's above all.
Love is what binds everything together.
How does it do that? Because God is love
and because Jesus in love sacrificed himself
for us, because he loves, he came and died.
So when we model that to one another,
when we willingly self-sacrifice for the good of someone else,
even when they don't deserve it, even when they could never pay us back.
When we do that because we love,
that's what knits us together as one body. Verse 15 says,
because God is love. That's what he does. That's his.
His whole character is love. And so he says,
you do that and it's going to work.
And it shows the world that we are a redeemed new creation.
People all living out this new self of God together.
It's what forgiveness does. It's what love does.
So you see this relational difference that's
supposed to be in the church,
which even leads then, I mean, just stop. Just stop and think about that.
If there's no broken relationships,
if everybody's walking in love that's binding us together in unity,
how sweet a place that is to be, right?
That's what then people look at and say, what do you guys have?
What's different about you?
I wanna be a part of that because it is so sweet to be
together. And what that does is it leads to a culture of celebration,
life giving joy. And that's what we see.
He even talks about here in verse 16, that that this new self,
the way it plays out among us, the way it changes our interactions,
it then even affects our worship in here.
As we gather in all kinds of other circles and dynamics out there,
it changes even our worship. It overflows that kind of inward heart.
Our relational context overflows into our worship gatherings.
We look at verse 16 again.
Let the word of Christ dwell in you.
Richly teaching and admonishing one another in all wisdom,
St singing Psalms and hymns and spiritual songs with thankfulness in your hearts
to God.
This is the responsiveness to God's word that he does and creates in us.
It creates disciple makers, admonishing, changing, teaching,
instructing each other. By the way, every one of you can do that.
That's a disciple making mentality is you are called to do that with others.
But then it also leads us to sing out of the overflow of our hearts.
And notice this says that this singing should
be able to happen regardless of the style.
'cause he mentions three styles, right? Psalms, hymns, spiritual songs,
those are all stylistic differences, different content in those things.
And he says,
we should be able to sing passionately to any of it.
Why? Because we have thankfulness in our hearts to God,
because it's in there, because we want to express it to him. We've been changed.
We've been given so much by God. Like let's just express it.
It doesn't matter what it is or how it is, I'm gonna sing.
But you might be sitting there saying, I'm not a singer.
Or you might say in general, like men just, people just don't sing anymore.
Especially men. Men don't sing
well as my friend Lee Corso says, not so fast, my friend,
while I was on sabbatical a couple months ago,
I had the privilege of attending a massive worship service where everyone
was singing men, women, children, and singing loudly.
In fact, I was, I was so moved by the experience, I just had to record it.
And so I, I'm gonna show us that here for a second.
Get the video going. You can hear it.
You got the video there. It is
powerful, isn't it? Of course.
I'm being somewhat facetious here.
That was Newcastle United celebrating going to the Champions league in
May.
And that was 50,000 people the entire game,
long singing, chanting, all in unison,
all together.
And so you see that people do sing.
Why do those people sing like that? Because it's in their hearts.
Because they find their identity in that team.
And because they're joining together with 49,999 other people
who all have it in their hearts, who are all passionate about the same thing,
finding their identity in that team. And they're saying, let's celebrate this.
So you can't tell me people won't sing. It's just not in our hearts.
It's just not deep down in there.
We're not as passionate about God as we think we are.
We're not truly thankful for all that he's done for us,
whether it's Psalms, hymns, or spiritual P songs. It doesn't matter.
I am going to celebrate the fact of God is who he says he is.
And I have been saved by him.
I think we're more concerned about what other people think about us than what we
want to do to respond to our God and Savior. That's right.
But did you see it here in Colossians three?
Part of what it means to put on the new self is that you are singing.
You don't have to be on American idol.
You don't have to be on the voice and prove yourself. You are singing to him,
right? Did you see it to God thankfulness. It's in your hearts to God,
not to the person next to you. And listen, I'm,
I don't want to, I don't want you to hear that.
I'm saying it like just condemning and trying to come down hard because what I
have seen, praise God,
is that it seems like every week we get together like this,
it's like our voices are getting a little bit louder and a little bit louder and
a little bit louder. Like God is working and making us and shaping us.
And it's, it's good news because here's what happens when those days come.
When you walk in here or I walk in here and I'm looking around at the world and
I'm saying, God, I,
it's hard for me to remember that you are who you say you are or you've done
what you've done. And I hear you singing those things to me,
over me. It lifts my heart,
it lifts my arms a little bit. And I pray it does that for you.
Notice this is again, group singing.
You're admonishing one another.
You're singing in a sense over one another to God because
it's in your heart.
So here's what I hope you've seen today. Church, this new creation,
kingdom of God is a whole different way of, of living.
It is radically different.
And that's what verse 17 summarizes. Look again.
He said all this, all this, all this, all this. And whatever you do
in word or deeded in voice or action,
do everything in the name of the Lord Jesus,
giving thanks to God the Father through him
this new self we're talking about, it should affect everything,
every corner of your heart. Everything you're thinking about right now is God.
Lord over that. Yes he is.
Should I do that or should I not do that? Can you do it in the name of Jesus?
That's his everything.
Because Christ the king is your identity. Now
He's given you a new identity. He's changed everything.
And it's like you're walking around. I've got this jersey up here.
This is my youngest son's fourth grade football jersey. Like,
it's like you're walking around with the team jersey on,
and the front of it is way more important than what's on the back, right?
Every team you've ever been on or every scene,
they are playing for the name on the front.
And so you're walking around with the jersey on to reflect and point
to the name on the front. But here's the reality.
The name on the back,
the reputation of the name on the back does affect how the front's viewed,
right?
And so we need to put on the new self such that the
front name, the name of the Lord Jesus, as he says here,
do everything in the name of the Lord Jesus. These your identity now.
And you go for him.
You're living a life on the backside that reflects this change he's made in you.
He gets more glory from that.
That's why this new self affects everything in our lives.
Because people need to see that this is what God does. And listen,
that means every word, every action, every thought. It is his,
his transformation is comprehensive
because remember,
his goal is to shape you into the image of Christ
whose perfect words, thoughts, actions,
everything gave us what the image of God looks like.
That would've stood out radically in Colossae,
a life like that dark, sinful place.
That was like radical difference.
What about today?
That's the same radical difference God's calling us to today
and listen, empowering us to today. He's the,
he's using us as the canvas. He's showing himself off. He's painting his love,
his forgiveness, his peace, his joy, his life.
He's painting it on our lives so that he shows off who
he is.
How are you doing at that church?
How are we doing collectively?
How are you doing individually at letting him
shape you into this new image?
Don't forget, remember if you've placed your faith in Jesus,
he already has made you new. So live it out
in the power of the spirit inside of you. Live it out
all for his glory.